[Music]
and welcome back to another exciting
episode of the careful boys well we're
extremely careful very very very very
very careful i'm gonna get a little bit
more personal again
and the prompt today is
the worst thing you ever lied about
we'll not have to worry about that we're
dumbest or dumbest we can go dumbest
dumbest
don't miss
dumbest thing i lied about
this one took a little bit of
preparation because i suppress most of
my lives until they become truths
do they become truths
yeah because he's delusional
okay i'll give you a warm-up one i'll
start so it's easy
uh my parents told me never to tell a
stranger
what my name was like never talk to
strangers don't if they ask your name
they anything don't talk to them so i
got lost at uh at fedco
when i was four years old
they couldn't find me and then so i went
to the front desk
and they were like yeah just tell us
your name and then we'll we'll uh page
your parents they'll come right
i know what you're trying to do
you're gonna get me that meat [ __ ]
my mom warned me about this goddammit
like i told her my name was jason
because i saw in sesame street that
morning there's a cool tap dancer named
jason
from jason now that you're older you
know he wasn't cool
and they just kept going well jason's
parents please come in the front your
son's lost my parents never [ __ ]
showed up because
your parents
they're probably like just oh so many
kids today is like
so many kids are being
lost oh that one's not ours don't worry
that is a different one they came like
super late and they were like why did
you say your name was jason you idiot
like you told me not to tell strangers
my name
but then you hang out with the strangers
the whole time that's the best one
that's the dumbest thing i lied about
there's a critical flaw in their logic i
hope that they knew that yeah i mean oh
i know the dumbest thing a lot about so
like i remember like fifth grade or
sixth grade that's when uh
like
dying her hair started to come in
and everyone was using like they're like
bleaching sun or sun exactly right and
then specifically the bangs i'm like
yeah i'm like [ __ ] i don't know if i can
like
show up
and then have my hair be blonde and then
my parents go
hmm i don't notice anything different
you know and then that's when i found
out about sun in
where you just slowly like
spray right and every day it's like
fading a little bit
so i had sprayed a little bit by little
and i remember like i'd be eating dinner
and my mom's like
your hair getting lighter
snow
and then it would slowly get like
lighter lighter and lighter and pretty
soon it was like just like my veins are
completely blonde right and she's like
what the [ __ ] is going on with your hair
i'm like oh [ __ ] you know what happened
i think i bought my friend's helmet and
he had like hydrogen peroxide
that's so elaborate what's stupid
and i was like and now that i think
about it i do remember this tingly
feeling when i was riding my bike
and i was like i hope it's not getting
bleached
hydrogen peroxide like you should see my
friend and your friend's like just a
[ __ ] bald head with his eyeballs
coming out he's like kill me
let me
die hydrogen peroxide in my health and
every day why do i do it to myself i
gotta go i gotta go with it no he said
it makes the bike faster
i should just
hide in his helmet
damn that's a pretty [ __ ] rock star
lie dude okay so i was i for context i
grew up with mostly like my mom and then
my two older sisters were about seven
and six and seven years older than me so
i grew up with like three moms of [ __ ]
so i would i was getting in trouble all
the time i was probably in like fifth
grade
i was mad at my mom because she [ __ ]
beat the [ __ ] i mean she like i was
[ __ ] around she smacked me up so i
want to get back at her right i want to
get back so she had a little like a
drawer in the living room and i took a
sharpie and i thought i was really gonna
[ __ ] stick it to her by doing this i
took the sharpie and i wrote her name
just on it on what on just the bottom of
the the cabinet
just in the drawer i just wrote her name
in a sharpie [ __ ] you and her name is
margaret
but i spelled it as mar great
because i'm stupid
right
you're [ __ ] dumb dude this is a
vengeance plot
hold on hold on it's gonna get better
okay
so so i do this i do this a couple days
later my mom goes nick and i'm like what
she's like get in here and i walk in i'm
like what like what are you talking
about like what
she pulled i see the drawer open and
she's like
did you do this
and i go
what is that i do that
what
[ __ ] going for the eyes bro i'm
squinting like
no i she's like did you do this and it's
clearly my hand right
it's [ __ ] fourth grade handwriting
you know it's clearly my handwriting and
the name is entendre
my sisters are way older and [ __ ] right
they're like they all [ __ ] knew they
saw it they [ __ ] stitched on me and
[ __ ] i'm looking at and she's looking at
me like you [ __ ] did this and i go i
don't know what you're talking about
i just keep the nice
cold and then she beat my [ __ ] ass
the rest of the day yeah
that was one of the dumbest things i
[ __ ] lied about i have plenty of
things as long as you never never let up
on the live yeah i was like what are you
talking about and it's it's still in my
mom's house today
you know what i'll take a picture i'll
take a picture
graffiti kid strikes again
tell her to take a photo right now send
it to you i want to text her right now
that wrote that called you great
ingenious ocean 11 heist i did remember
when i was baby banksy
i can't believe she beat your ass i
would be in tears laughing so hard she
wrote happy mother's day under it it's
hard to make it's my heart i ate his ass
while she was laughing no she wasn't
laughing she was like this my kid is
stupid that's what she was like my kid
is a [ __ ] dumb
get you get angry though because you
you're like okay this is going to lead
to the next
lie next time
ignore me
we can't
musical grab a [ __ ] delivery wild has
to go appears
delivery too soon we love you right [ __ ]
it keep it in there easter egg easter
egg dude
dude marguerite
oh my god
like a uh steal some [ __ ] oreos and
he just hid behind the counter
and i was like what are you doing back
there and you don't even see him he's
just like
nothing
oh my god this [ __ ] so i go i'm
like did you steal oreos and he has
[ __ ] crumbs all over his face
no
i'm like oh it was so cute but you had
to get him in trouble i'm like i got
smacked in the butt you lied to me i'm
like i told you if you if you [ __ ] up i
don't care but if you [ __ ] up and you
lie i'm like that's gonna smack you so i
smacked him in the butt
and then you [ __ ] flew like six feet
flew right back into the bag of oreos
you had more oreos volleyball served
you guys ever have a situation where
like your friends are a little bit like
more grown up than you so they more know
sick like they know more sexual [ __ ] bad
words whatever right and then like you
don't want to be the innocent one so
like you pretend like oh yeah you know
what that is right so like
i was at my friend's house and they're
all talking about like sex and [ __ ] and
like i don't know what the [ __ ] that is
like we're like in fourth grade or
something right and he's talking about
condoms and then like
and they're like you don't know what a
condom is like oh no no i know we have
it at the house and they're like oh yeah
and i was like [ __ ] i don't know what it
is but i don't want to seem stupid right
and then they're just talking about it
and i was like well but tell me what
does it look like because i'm thinking
maybe i could go into the medicine
cabinet or like i can find this thing
and then show them like i have it
because we were talking about like oh we
should get one and we can all like kind
of look at it and they're talking about
yeah there's check it out we can all use
one
together like once that's like banana
and then all this stuff and i'm like how
the [ __ ] do these guys know this and my
parents didn't tell me [ __ ] right
but then the whole time i'm like man
yeah [ __ ] i know what a condom is and i
think they caught on to my lie so they
kept pressing me about it and i was like
no you tell me if you know cause i'm
like give me as much description as
as you can give me so i can find this
[ __ ] [ __ ] i need to shoot this thing
right and then they call me out on it
they're like go [ __ ] home right now
go get some for us and i'm all like all
right [ __ ] because i think at this point
i have enough information for me to go
and identify what this thing is right so
i run home sanitizer and i'm like going
through all the [ __ ] cabinets i'm
like [ __ ] i can't fail this [ __ ] and
look like a little [ __ ] right and then
my mom's like what are you looking for
and i'm like condoms and i'm just like
looking
i don't know it's like bad i need them
now
you weren't even close to what they were
if you said that to your mother that was
like condoms and she's like
she was getting like [ __ ] mad like
why do you need that you don't need this
and i'm like no i do i do i do
can you imagine like making a mess in
the house dude i gotta buy condoms and
then she grabs my dad and they're like
worried because i'm okay like the way
you you know it probably looks like a
fourth grader is going to go and [ __ ] a
girl yeah and then he looks like that
they haven't had that talk what's your
bust dude yeah i'm killing it and then
i'm like i go to the kitchen i'm like we
need it it's it's okay
it's like a rubber it looks like this
there's a it kind of like a glove but
just one and then like you put it into
them like they don't know what god does
it's the one thing it's a new thing
stop [ __ ] with me dad i need some one
finger glove my [ __ ] reputation right
and then like they're like no you're not
going back out and i'm like no no and
then i and i find something in the
kitchen i grab a handful and i'm like
this i needed this and then i just
[ __ ] bone out i go back right and i
come back they're all waiting for me i
[ __ ] throw it down and then they're
like
joseph those are rubber bands
this straight up bags dude no rubber
bands oh bam cause in my head i was it's
rubber there's you know it bands around
it's [ __ ] put put it around your dick
so i grab rubber bands
but the thick ones that you get at the
grocery store for your vegetables the
ones that hold the lobster [ __ ] yeah
like those the blue ones
with expiration
yeah it was like that and i was like
well i don't know about the balloon part
but maybe this is like close enough
so i [ __ ] i threw it on the ground
like bam and then they started dying bro
they were [ __ ] dying and then they
were all like let's put on our condoms
guys and then like putting it on and
like
and then so they they're laughing and
then so they told their mom like and
then um you know their mom's like this
young like cool like [ __ ] like kind
of like gangster mom like she didn't
give a [ __ ] and she started dying and
the whole family was making fun of me
laughing at you everyone had a cool
gangster mom and then they had and then
and then she had to talk to my parents
about what happened and then
my parents were laughing at me because i
don't know you know they're like yeah we
never talked about sex and [ __ ]
right
they had they handed him the [ __ ]
rubber bands like take this thing is the
next day his mom sat me down and showed
me what a real condom was and she put it
on and she put it in her mouth and then
she yeah
she's like go ahead you can you can like
open this up you know and then i was
like
i was like this is not fair like why did
my parents embarrass me and not [ __ ]
tell me jack [ __ ] and this stranger's
well not strange my friend's mom's
having this talk with me and then she's
like unrolling it she goes this is what
you use when you're an adult and then
like my friend's standing there giggling
because he's fourth grade
huh this is you're in fourth grade yeah
like fourth grade issue they had sex ed
at that time in elementary school right
now
well i went to public school i just was
like sixth grade but we didn't get the
sex talk until like junior high
yeah hell no i definitely didn't get the
condom talk like i still didn't know
what that was none of my friends were
[ __ ] by the way they were just
pretending like they they knew but it's
because like their parents were like
degenerates and [ __ ] they just had
condoms they did random [ __ ] they saw
porno they saw this stuff i didn't see
any of it right but then his mom was
cool enough to be like look like this is
what adults use and this is for
protection because you don't want sexual
whatever and i was like well thanks for
telling me [ __ ] now i'm not a [ __ ]
dumbass he's like can we try now dude
not sure she was uh she didn't look good
actually
she's a cool gangster mom the cool
gangster mom i was picturing like a
michelle rodriguez or something yeah
yeah no but um
nah dude she was she was really big that
and she didn't know her size but like
she she wore skimpy outfits it was so
funny oh she knew her size
she would be coming out and i'll put it
like mini skirts and her [ __ ]
boyfriend would be like damn look at
that hot mama wow
i'm just like oh my god she's so fat
just the honest kid in you yeah in my
head i don't know
but yeah that was out loud
she's so fat perfect so now we got
ammunition on joe
they don't know what a copper is a
rubber band just throw rubber bands
everywhere
but i guess uh at from that point i was
like i should just [ __ ] admit that i
don't know
and if that little embarrassment was
better than the big one oh yeah yeah
that's always the way it goes bad they
[ __ ] went now let's put our condoms
on
in that voice dude that's what sucks you
get like you let them have one thing and
that thing gets stretched out for like
three years yeah you're like mother
every time a rubber band i don't think
you do
i don't think you do yeah me neither no
it's only been like a year yeah i
thought you'd get a saran wrap put the
saran wrap over your dick and wrap a
rubber band that's a pretty good that's
pretty good though
that's probably that's like a dental dam
yeah that's an old-school condom dude
macgyver condom
it's better than nothing i bet damn that
was a really good story
i think i uh i'll try i'll try and pull
a story from when i was a little older
so it feels dumber yeah
a little less epic but um
that tells the kindred story shut up i
remember i had a
i had a uh a bubbler you know for weed
yeah and that's it's there's no denying
what that is right that's like clearly
what it is right and then i i was
probably 25 or something done moving
from like one apartment to another hats
a couple boxes that i need to bring home
you know be in the transition of the
move uh and by the time i got into this
other apartment i remember looking for
this bubbler and i couldn't find it kept
on trying to find it over and over and
then i realized that like this no no
it's like just maybe like this this big
just had like two chambers one of those
things you know put water in this water
bubbler you know so it makes it bubbler
and then
i thought to myself maybe it's at home
all right i finally got home uh and then
i'm looking for this thing and then
finally my mom's like
hey uh
do you uh smoke
and i'm like
no what are you talking about
she's like oh you sure i'm like yeah for
sure she's like
i found something and i was like
would you find
she
tries to describe this stuff
right she's like
i think it's something you smoke with a
butler
the bubbler man
[Laughter]
so i say the same [ __ ] that i probably
said when i was like five years old i
was like
oh that's my friends right i'm trying to
explain this thing to my friends but
that's so smart we smoked together but
he left it at my house
but but when you're an adult the
shittiness of trying to still hold that
conviction to your parents and your
parents looking at you like
okay because there's no point in trying
to argue as well yeah but then my my
extra dumb ass you know after like an
awkward moment of silence still goes
do you still have it
oh no she's like no i threw it away i
was like oh
i wanted to give that back to my friend
and then from that on i'm pretty damn
sure she knows i smoke but other than
that i still didn't get in trouble or
nothing no because i was like 25
you're smoking at four though it was a
disappointment more than anger you know
what i mean just that shitty part yeah
but you still like i i don't have the
heart to be like yes
this is what i do i'm an adult what
about now have you ever brought that
back up and like no i never brought it
up no need to call her we should call
her right now right now call her out
right now you shouldn't there's no way
she has to be reimbursed for that yeah
i'll call my mom tell her sorry about
the condom dude where it's like
disappointment is like 10 times worse
than anger tell her you used to smoke
salvia i'll tell i'll tell my mom it
wasn't the helmet
and i'll tell my mom it was me dude i'll
tell them mom i didn't need condos i'll
tell my mom i'm not jason
see it's all fair we all do at the same
time i still win save time simultaneous
speakerphones so they're all just like
that's just gonna like hurt her heart
again for no reason she's just like
thinking about something else i'm just
gonna hear i know
i know
i know i [ __ ] know i'm not an idiot
you think oh yeah your friend's putting
hydrogen peroxide in his helmet
i could feel it i can't wait for the
lies they're gonna have yeah like
there's gonna be a lot of [ __ ] oh
yeah shitty follow-up kid lie i remember
uh we had a pool day you know what i
mean you know when you have pool days in
elementary school
and uh i remember me and my buddy uh
kept on pretending that we had dropped a
quarter at the bottom of the pool giving
us an excuse to constantly dive down
only so we could stare at panties
[Music]
you kid perv
there's so many quarters down there oh
wait how so
it's probably like third grade yeah it's
a pool day and you're just kind of like
everybody's like oh my god look she's in
her
underwear you know what i mean you're
like like how do we see it like oh i
dropped a quarter now i gotta find it
and just keep on saying the same [ __ ]
thing
let's practice holding our breath as
long as we can yeah exactly
he had his own excuse
he did that [ __ ] too with a different
reason
you're probably like let's do a tea
party what's a tea party all right what
about you everyone how it starts really
early though man
like kindergarten do you think kids
modern kids still perval they have to is
it perv or is it curiosity at that age i
think it's curious because i don't even
know what sex was what to do with it
yeah i was like we didn't know we were
perfect now [ __ ] how i have to touch you
guys of course they prove out what are
you talking about i remember me and my
friend we would watch we would watch
baywatch
and then like every now and then
it's like non-stop doesn't mean it's
just a white people thing dude it's a
human nature thing to do
no we'd be like seven all watching
baywatch all of us have [ __ ] like
little heart boners and we would all
stick our dicks at the screen at the tv
yeah we don't know why it's attractive
it's like magnetic yeah whoa
yeah it's like the poltergeist show and
we'll just all stick our dicks there
like we're [ __ ] like towards mecca
just showing each other your like lumps
yeah
just like flicking them
yeah
for me it's really stupid it's [ __ ]
stupid right
so i remember i hope so i remember like
my eyebrows like some some chick
commented my eyebrows were really bushy
and i was like [ __ ] you talking about
bishi right so i was like and i was
looking at him in the mirror and i was
like all right i guess i got to do
something about this so i just started
like plucking like pulling the what i
thought was black
with your hands with my fingers yeah cuz
i don't know about [ __ ] your hard
core i'm in like middle school or
something early middle school and i'm
like i'm like all right [ __ ] all
right and then i go to school the next
day and they're all red because they
were bleeding and [ __ ]
and she's like
did you pluck your eyebrows and i was
like no no pimples dudes [ __ ] pimples
dude
i gotta moisturize my [ __ ] big time you
know like just totally
of course i did that and
yeah the fact that she called it out
immediately like she knew it looked like
i went to war that the night before it
was crazy because i like your nails
digging into your thing and you're
plucking out and it's bleeding
i'm surprised you didn't go to like your
mom or sister and get tweezers i don't
even know about that i didn't [ __ ]
know what to teach you i know that you
tweezers were the fourth for that i had
no idea
it's like how would you know that yeah
that's like saying why don't you just go
to the freaking indian district and get
threading done
[ __ ]
or get hydrogen box on your [ __ ]
helmet
i don't think i was taught like hygiene
beyond [ __ ] shampoo and soap and
conditioner it's not a guy thing to not
like scrub and then just yeah be like
lotiony
[ __ ] i didn't even [ __ ] know i was
supposed to pull my foreskin back and
clean that me neither oh whoa i don't
even know that but i just took a turn by
the time i got that check before my
surgery the doctor was like hey you ever
clean that
no no oh god this is going to be a time
when was your surgery
when i was when i was 13. okay okay
that's better
that's better circumcision at 13. well
no no at least no chicks had to deal
with it first i hope well
[Laughter]
just all right just uh i'm gonna i'm
gonna count three two one after one
everybody just point at who you think
was the dumbest story okay the dumbest
story on this live dumbass
line don't believe me remember promise
live
here okay all right go all right all
right just real quick just to recap just
recap okay his this is jason over here
this is more great over here
this is hydrogen peroxide over here i
think the iron over there this is the
bubbler over here
okay this is the rubber band condoms
okay all right eyebrows and eyebrows
okay after one we don't even need it
three two one more great
that's the worst that i've ever heard
that you thought you thought you were
dissing your mom by writing her name
down
but misspelling it [ __ ] hilarious i
got one more too but bart's bart's
excuse was funnier i was pointing out
hydrogen peroxide me too the excuse of
the helmet having hydrogen peroxide is
just pretty good
[Music]
oh
[Music]